équité qualité d'être calme qui est-ce
service de messagerie d'humeur égale Mars
tu dois jouer à nouveau pour donner la mauvaise
maison appelée tais-toi à moins que tu ne veuilles dire que
j'aime ce jeu tu es un
détective privé juste vingt dollars là-dedans d'
accord prends-le maintenant  Je ne suis pas là
pour ça je messager donne moi un bras gauche
non viens non quand tu parles à
ton médecin
ouais dis lui que tu as un ami en spirale
tu sais respirer profondément je ne suis pas dans les
pages jaunes si tu as des problèmes  avec
quelqu'un
pourrait demander autour de moi Jackson Ely Je
travaille pour le ministère de la Justice
ma fille Melia est en danger s'il vous plaît
trouvez-la protégez-la
March Jackie Lee Je suis Nadia deux envies
quand je vous pose une question
non stupide pensez-vous que je suis je  a un
permis de transport ne gâche pas ça
depuis ta petite visite ce petit
bébé va rester ici ne bouge pas la
racaille ce que la confiance heureuse dit que tu es
plutôt bon dans ce domaine je veux que tu trouves un
médium je penserais que ton  le travail s'est terminé
en me cassant le [ __ ] de bras tu es le
mec qui a battu mon père hé meunier a
frappé ton père grande différence en voyant
cette fille elle a des cheveux noirs s'appelle
Amelia ce qu'il y a dedans pour moi il arrêtera de le
faire en faisant quoi oh [ __ ] papa
papa il y a comme des [ __ ] ici et des trucs
ma chérie combien de fois ont  Je t'ai dit de
ne pas dire et des trucs dis juste que papa
il y a des [ __ ] ici la foule essaie
d'étendre son opération à Los Angeles d'une
manière ou d'une autre Familia est impliquée une chose que nous
savons avec certitude que
quelque chose de drôle se passe
oh ça ne cesse de s'améliorer mieux
le  le pire détective du monde le
pire
regard du monde sur le bon côté personne n'a été blessé
elle l'a eue je dis je pense qu'ils sont morts
rapidement donc je ne pense pas
qu'ils aient été blessés